texas democrats voting stunt now turning
into a super
spreader tour that sounds like fun but
the media is nowhere to be found there's
no widespread
outrage condemnation or even claims
these democrats
are going to slaughter americans five
texas state lawmakers so far
have tested positive for kovid after
fleeing their state and posing for
selfies
masculists on private planes the group
going all around d.c last week
meeting with top democrats like chuck
schumer having a
with liz warren that's not tasteful and
potentially exposing kamala harris to
the virus
the vp even made a trip to walter reed
medical center yesterday
but the white house is calling that
visit a routine appointment
and jed sackey doesn't seem to be
concerned in the least bit
is there any safety concern about her
spending time around the president
until a certain amount of time has
passed that she was tested
and that she did there was no detection
of kovid 19 there's no separation of the
president of the vice president there
haven't been additional precautions
taken no
do officials here wish that those texas
democrats would have been more
careful and taken more precautions like
wearing masks on the flight here
again i don't think i'm i'm going to uh
be in a position here to assess what
safety precautions they may or may not
have taken
ainsley welcome to the show thank you
greg i'm not used to having someone
taller than me
up to my right i am sitting on a pillow
oh these chairs are very low
they're gonna take it off okay here we
go you think we could afford better
chairs
you know what though you know what's
great about these democrats they thought
they were fred uh frederick douglass but
they look more like fred flintstone
they've really turned into kind of a
cartoonish uh
a vision of what they thought they were
gonna be i wonder what kamala thinks of
them now remember she called them heroes
and she said this routine doctor's
appointment on a sunday who gets a
checkup on a sunday
but i wrote down a few things when i
started just thinking about
how this all has unfolded they
filibuster in texas yet they go to
washington encouraging the dems
to eliminate the filibuster they want
everyone in masks on
airplanes you have to wear a mask when
you get on an airplane and sometimes you
have to wear it indoors now even if
you're vaccinated
yet they didn't wear them on these
private planes they fly on their private
planes to d.c
and they stay in hotels with laundry
service yet they claim hardships they
say
sacrifices when they have to wash and
hang their wet clothes
sometimes their underwear in the
bathrooms and they tweet about it
kamala harris says if you are exposed
you need to quarantine
she met with them on tuesday some of
them
were testing positive at the end of the
week yet when the democrats asked her
when
when the media asked her are you going
to quarantine her spokesperson says she
didn't need to do it
i'm looking at polling right now
according to the
convention of states action and
trafalgar survey
polling for her is so low y'all she has
64 percent of the voters saying she is
not ready to be president and 43 percent
of them are democrats and then where is
the media outrage greg mm-hmm
no i i have this uh uh this equation
it's like
what would m do if it was r and not d
what would the media do if it was
republicans and not democrats they'd be
we'd be murderers anybody to the right
who was it was part of this would be
murderers
lawrence this seems to me like the worst
trip since ainsley took mushrooms in
college
never done it never done it um
on a serious note i think your open was
correct
this was about the moment the fact that
they wanted to paint it themselves
like mlk they wanted to be douglas but
you got to do the work to be
douglas you got to do the work to be mlk
and i think
from a media standpoint they stumbled
because the moment never produced itself
let's be honest what's getting ready to
happen
the bill is going to be passed right
they're going to be arrested when they
come back to the state of texas
they won't be written in the history
books the media won't
cover their story anymore and every
single thing that the republicans wanted
after negotiating with them for months
is going to be
drafted in this bill so the question is
where do we go from here
they got to run on this now i mean
they're already in the democratic
national committee
uh is already investing in this but it
was never about
texas by h.r hr1 it's about federalizing
this they're gonna say
look we tried to fight back in texas
even though politico gave us four
pinocchios just like georgia
uh we've tried to fight and and this is
why we have to run on this in the next
election that it has to be a federalized
election system
and then that's when you're going to see
the voters push back because if you know
anything about southern states
especially the state of texas
we don't like the feds being involved in
our election system it's going to
backfire
i was dismayed that these were actually
democrats from texas
yeah because i thought they'd be a
little bit different if they get
arrested they can't go to jail though
because the jails won't hold covid
patients right
yeah right oh that's a good point
richard what do you make of this are we
overstating this you must admit though
that there is quite an imbalance from
the media perspective like the media
this is not a story but if you just
reversed it it would be
leading every show on every network
listen you know i call balls and strikes
so where i will call this strike on this
one that's baseball correct
that is baseball thank you just make
sure you know your sports uh listen so i
where i will give where i will give a
strike here is that they should have had
mask on the plane you can't say that you
want everybody else to wear mask in the
general public and then you don't wear
mask on a plane so this is where we call
it strike
now where i think we like we're hearing
lies the problem there are democrats
joe manchin and others that are actually
trying to pass the john lewis voting
rights act now the john lewis voting
rights act is the rename
of the 1965 voting rights act that was
passed by lbj
that was repassed by ronald reagan that
was signed by george h.w bush that was
signed by george w bush
it is a very basic piece of law that was
by that has been bipartisan ever since
what it says and in states where there
is actual voter suppression a history of
voter suppression
that there should be pre-clearance by
the justice department for new voter
rules
this bill can get passed right this bill
has bipartisan support in the senate it
needs 10 votes it's very close to
getting that
and i think this story creates a mass we
should be having a conversation
about the john lewis voting rights act
in this segment instead we're talking
about these
the problem is they're appearing what
happened during the pandemic
as civil rights legislation this was
supposed to be temporary
to your point let's also remember that
during the last election we had
more voters vote than ever that's a fair
point though this was
we were told everything that we were
being told was temporary without being
told permanently
but wait a minute but wait a minute to
be fair in this past election right
there was no
widespread voter fraud that we could
that has that passes the
the court test right no federal judge
has said we've seen widespread votes
i've been looking at
they've i mean i think with i don't know
there's been more than 48 50 cases
yeah all these cases including the
supreme court twice
but the rhetoric from the left about
what the the texas republicans want to
do
is just a full picture of hogwash
let me finish that somehow you need
24-hour a day drive-in voting
and if you don't get that which was
during the pandemic in
one part of texas then that's jim crow
8.0 that's what doesn't make any sense
i want to [ __ ] can i just quickly focus
on uh the whole issue of covid
of these democrats it doesn't sound like
anybody's sick so wouldn't this be a
success story
if they were totally if they were fully
vaccinated and you have
even if you have a case it's mild it's
asymptomatic wouldn't that be something
they would be crying about but i can
tell you
that the percentage of people who they
say they were fully vaccinated
are they telling the truth because the
percentage of people who got covered
from being on this plane is way out of
whack with the study from harvard
it's one out of 10 000 people who are
vaccinated
get breakthrough covet this is like
based on
just simple back of the envelope math
it's about ten percent right
it might be even more so is somebody not
telling the truth here
believe it number one number two kamala
harris should be
treating this as a non-event going about
her business because that's the message
if you're vaccinated that you want to
send to the american people
if you come in contact with somebody who
has gotten coveted i've been vaccinated
going about my business um you want to
ask me about the media yeah what about
the media dagen
i i fully expect
the screeching shrieking preening
peacocks
and peahens in the media to totally go
silent when their fellow
asshats uh in the left wing in the
democratic party
um make butts out of themselves by
completely not
following the norms and rules that they
breathlessly preach to each other i just
think we should be having conversations
you know what they're busy looking for
their next they always have that we have
that comfort we have that conversation
every day
and meanwhile we're bringing not voter
fraud voting rights yeah no no we have
talked about voting rights it's very
simple voter id
we've been told that i'm not aggressive
i know but i'm pretty much right
you're bringing this up let's let's get
right to the heart of it you guys
are saying that voter id is the worst
thing since the
that's not what i'm saying well i'm
telling your team that you're defending
i'm just saying it should be a college
id it should be a utility bill
it should be anything that identifies
who you are and where you live can we
compromise on that i say then
then democrats need to say yes everyone
has to have a voter id
and then i think republicans can say so
what we'll let you vote in the middle of
the night if you want to go into this
fine
i'm also for a voter holiday if you want
to make election day holiday on for that
this is for you yes while the left-wing
media is ignoring what's going on with
these texas democrats
i'm sure they're out looking for their
next michael avenatti hey sean hannity
here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else